io ormai diciamo non sono più nuovo a
questi tipi di eventi sicuramente la
prima volta e mi fa molto piacere sono
molto onorato perfette dx da ragazzo del
sud giovane del sud perché si fa a lecce
perché a lecce si parla di innovazione
che non è solo tecnologico ma anche
innovazione sociale
la cosa strana è che spesso mi invitano
diciamo parlare in questi eventi lo
dicevo prima gianluca lettori ad altri
amici a parlare di antimafia sembra che
fare antimafia sociale sia un qualcosa
che porti innovazione
io spero che nel giro di qualche anno
non se non sarà più innovativo fare
lotta alla mafia ma sarà la normalità
che abbatteremo questo diciamo digital
divided sul sul tema un tema che noi
stiamo iniziando ormai a vedere ogni
giorno sulle cronache dei quotidiani e
ai telegiornali ma dove purtroppo spesso
faticano a emergere le buone notizie
l'albero che cade fa più rumore della
foresta che cresce
ho preparato delle slide per facilitare
un po mio speech di oggi
quello è un dato di luglio del 2012 è
recentissimo nel 2006 di luglio 2012
in italia il 35,3 per cento dei giovani
tra i 15 ei 24 anni sono disoccupati lo
dice l'istat
un altro istituto di ricerca lo svimez
per lo sviluppo dell'industria nel
mezzogiorno dice che in italia vi è un
gap economico e socio culturale
soprattutto economico tra nord e sud
notevolissimo e che per colmare questo
gap questa differenza abissale tra nord
e sud per mettere il sud alla pari del
nord sarebbero necessari qualcosa come
400 anni quattro secoli per portare il
sud alla pari del nord
questo è un dato indicativo il 35,3 per
cento dei giovani c'è un giovane più di
un giovane su tre
come si entra nella criminalità
organizzata delle volte capita anche per
sbaglio 5 euro un bambino che fa il palo
fa il palo magari davanti a una sala
giochi dove un ragazzo poco più grande
di lui entra ed esce a seconda degli
scambi di droga droghe leggere che
effettua e il ragazzo che magari non è
un figlio di un mafioso
il bambino perché parliamo di bambini la
mafia le mafie e reclutano i bambini
ormai con 5 euro
riesce a essere in qualche modo
riconoscente a questa organizzazione
anche se il cerchio più ampio
non è ovviamente lacrime da organizzata
in senso in senso stretto però poi 5
euro che un ragazzo poco più grande di
lui gli dà in cambio dei suoi occhi
delle sue orecchie nella sua bocca
perché quei bambini vengono messi agli
angoli delle strade a fare diciamo la
guardiania e gli specchietti sti come
vengono definiti dalle parti di napoli i
pali il ragazzo che però sta dentro
entrare esce un ragazzo di 15 16 anni
soprattutto sicuramente ragazzi con meno
di 18 anni arriva a guadagnare qualcosa
come 700 e 900 euro a settimana
900 euro a settimana per fare un
traffico di droga
e ovvio che piano piano si parte dalle
piccole si arriva poi al grande sistema
il grande sistema un sistema che è fatto
di tanti elementi tanti elementi perché
se le mafie oggi esistono noi parliamo
oggi a lecce che è un territorio che
sicuramente negli anni passati nello
scorso decennio ha avuto tanti problemi
oggi si parla di più di calabria si
parla di più di campania si parla ancora
di sicilia ma il fenomeno non è
assolutamente debellato quello che
succede però dalle mie parti e anche
fuori ormai perché il modello è stato
esportato come un business vincente
il format ormai è andato al di fuori dei
confini
dobbiamo parlare di un vero e proprio
welfare delle mafie di mafia che ti
danno protezione di mafia che fanno
giustizia di buffy e che ti danno la
linea di credito sempre aperta quanti
piccoli commercianti e imprenditori
purtroppo si ritrovano messi con le
spalle al muro non hanno modo di avere
quel piccolo sussidio quella boccata
d'ossigeno che spesso e volentieri lo
stato non riesce a dare che purtroppo
neanche il sistema del credito delle
banche garantisce e quello è
l'anticamera si fa un vero e proprio
welfare cioè le mafie vengono percepiti
come una prossimità e danno al cittadino
tra virgolette tuttora serie di servizi
tutta una serie di servizi anche chi
paga il pizzo in sicilia lo considera
come se fosse una tassa come siete
pagare l'irap come se deve versare l'iva
come se deve pagare i suoi dipendenti e
quindi avere delle imposte che che
possano poi essere andate a completare
possano andare a completare quelli che
sono i costi dell'impresa però in cambio
del pizzo quel cittadino sa che alla sua
serranda nessuno andrà a mettere magari
un ordigno che nessuno
andrà a rubare dentro quel negozio
dentro quell attività commerciale
ecco purtroppo noi abbiamo iniziato a
renderci conto di questo problema di
come si combattono le mafie come abbiamo
visto che effettivamente veniva visto
diciamo questa prossimità non poteva non
riuscivamo a contrastarla in alcun modo
perchè pensavamo che era soltanto un
compito delle forze dell'ordine della
magistratura e di quella parte della
politica sana e allora noi dobbiamo
smascherare l'inganno delle mafie è un
inganno vero e proprio promettono
ricchezza promettono sviluppo promettono
benessere ma in realtà di dove ci sono
le mafie non c'è mai sviluppo non c'è
mai benessere non c'è mai ricchezza
soprattutto i boss stanno a contare i
loro soldi nei paradisi fiscali stanno a
a godersi i loro anni anni decenni di
latitanza mentre vengono arrestati poi
quei giovani ragazzi che entrano nel
meccanismo della mafia che da bambini
fanno i pali da grandi iniziano a
smerciare droga leggera e poi faranno i
corrieri della cocaina tra reggio
calabria e milano e poi ancora lucano in
questo modo però diventano schiavi da
cittadini con dei diritti e dei doveri
si trasformano in schiavi che hanno una
sorta di debito di riconoscenza nei
confronti di chi li garantisce un
sistema funzionale di welfare con il
traffico di cocaina e la ndrangheta in
cassa mediamente 45 miliardi di euro in
un anno
e queste sono stime fatte ovviamente per
difetto cioè non abbiamo la possibilità
di leggere i bilanci della ndrangheta
però sappiamo che sono 45 miliardi di
euro in un anno
quando vado da ragazzi nelle scuole devo
convincerli a stare in una squadra che
tante tante volte inferiore alla squadra
che è stata all'altra parte perché
purtroppo nella mia regione per esempio
in calabria
l'economia legale produce un qualcosa
come 5 miliardi di euro all'anno
quindi stiamo parlando di un qualcosa di
nove volte in meno di questo tipo di
traffici
c'è un episodio emblematico siamo nel
1989 l'on nel 2012 a berlino laddove
appena avvenuta la riunificazione delle
due germanie
c'è un
un militare un soldato diciamo della
ndrangheta che si trova lì e chiama il
suo capo in calabria e gli dice sono e
berlino che cosa devo fare
compra tutto gli dice compra tutto tutto
quello che riesce a comprare bar
ristoranti negozi tutto quello che puoi
comprare compralo la ndrangheta sapeva
già come reinvestire propri soldi fuori
dall italia siamo molti e molti anni
prima di quella che divenne nota come la
strage di duisburg che ci fece conoscere
anche al resto d'europa come
organizzazione criminale temibile che
fece conoscere la calabria e l'italia
all'europa e al mondo intero le mafie
sanno fare affari
oggi però non si tratta solo di mafia
perché abbiamo anche un fenomeno che è
quello del riciclaggio appunto e della
corruzione
i vari fiorito i vari lucino che
alimentano questo fenomeno noi ci
rendono anche famosi nel mondo è questo
è una vera e propria impresa
una mafia spa una quieta organizzata spa
che produce un giro d'affari di 100
miliardi di euro all'anno
stiamo parlando di una delle prime
aziende del paese un impero del crimine
appunto
noi dobbiamo fare una cosa quello che
possiamo fare noi cittadini assieme alle
istituzioni che quello che
ammazzatecitutti prova a fare ormai da
anni in tutta italia creando una vera e
propria rete che parte dei giovani
creare opinione pubblica avere degli
opinion leaders soprattutto tra la gente
ma anche sul web perché la siamo davvero
fortissimi fare in modo che ovunque ci
sia una piccola erbaccia che nasce che
inneggia a questo tipo di fenomeni
facebook per esempio abbiamo fatto
chiudere decine e decine di gruppi che
inneggiavano alla mafia alle mafie
purtroppo è un problema costante
puntualmente si ripresenta a fare
opinione pubblica vuol dire parlarne
parlarne nelle scuole parlare tra i
ragazzi fare il nostro ruolo di
cittadini anche questo è un modo di fare
innovazione
sembra strano parlare di lotta l'evento
organizzato oggi in italia è meno strano
parlarne al lecce però sembra poco ma
con quel popolo e riusciamo a fare
grandi cose e soprattutto attraverso la
rete
si diceva john lennon imagine all the
people caring al the world non
condividere tutto il mondo tutte le
persone che possono condividere tutto
quello che succede
e allora io penso che forse se noi
impariamo a condividere a usare facebook
i social network non soltanto per
scrivere cosa stiamo andando a fare in
quel particolare momento ma per fare in
modo che le buone notizie vengano
portate avanti ne abbiamo un sito
ammazzatecitutti punto org facciamo in
modo che le nostre attività vengano
condivise con una rete enorme stiamo
creando reti di persone la parola rete
una cosa bellissima perché in americano
si dice web ma in italia la parola rete
descrive tantissime cose prima ancora
che descrivere il web e internet
descrive le persone che si che entrano
in contatto tra di loro e questo forse
non è il migliore dei mondi possibili
però possiamo cambiarlo grazie